THE POST OFFICE AGAIN
>> HANNITY: JOINING US ON TWO
TOP STORE OTHERS, FORMER DEPUTY
ASSISTANT TO THE PRESIDENT FOX
NEWS NATIONAL SECURITY
STRATEGIST, SEBASTIAN, AND NRA
CONTRIBUTOR, DAN BON GENO, AND
GERALDO, YOU'RE OUTMANNED, SO
I'LL START WITH YOU BECAUSE OF
THAT REASON?
>> OUTGUNNED?
(LAUGHING)
>> HANNITY: NO, BUT THE THING
IS, YOU AGREE WITH ME, SECURE
THE PERIMETER, A FULL SECURITY
ASSESSMENT, EVERY SCHOOL ARMED,
RETIRED, CONCEALED CARRY,
POLICE, RETIRED MILITARY.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM.
WHEN YOU GO AROUND THE MILITARY
AND YOU'VE BEEN OUT WITH THEM,
THEY LOVE YOU.
POLICE IN NEW YORK LOVE YOU.
YOU HAVE ALWAYS FOUGHT FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT DEFEND OUR FREEDOMS
AND PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES.
I'VE NEVER HEARD OF A COP, EVER,
NOT
NO
NOT BEING SO PREPARED THAT THEY
WANT.
THIS IS -- IF THAT MOMENT COMES,
THEY WANT TO SAVE PEOPLE'S LIVES
>> I THINK WE HAVE A TENDENCY
THOUGH, SEAN, WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT, AND I LOVE COPS AND I
LOVE GIS, WE SOMETIMES IDEALIZE
THEM.
SCOTT PETERSON WAS BY ALL
ACCOUNTS A DONUT COP, WHAT A
CALL A DUNKING DONUT COP.
A COP THAT GOES AND SITS AND HAS
A BELLY AND DOESN'T DO MUCH.
THEN WHEN PUSH COMES TO SHOFB,
ONE THING I FOUND OUT IN ALL OF
MY WAR-TIME ASSIGNMENTS, 222
ASSIGNMENTS IN IRAQ AND
AFGHANISTAN, IS THAT COURAGE AND
COWARDESS IS DECIDED IN THE
BLINK OF AN EYE.
YOU NEVER KNOW HOW YOU'RE GOING
TO RESPOND.
THE PRESIDENT SAID HE WOULD
CHARGE IN.
HE DOESN'T REALLY KNOW.
YOU ONLY KNOW WHEN
>> HANNITY: WELL, HE DID HAVE
AN INCIDENT THAT WE KNOW ABOUT.
>> RIGHT.
WELL, WHAT I'M SAYING IS YOU
EITHER CHICKEN OUT OR YOU CHARGE
IN AND YOU'RE A HERO.
MEDAL OF HONOR WINNERS DIDN'T
PONDER THAT.
WE ALL HAVE OUR OWN THING
>> HANNITY: BUT THEY'RE TRAINED
AND MENTALLY THEY PREPARE FOR
THOSE MOMENTS.
THAT'S WHAT THEY TRAIN SO HARD
FOR
>> THAT'S WHAT THE INVESTIGATION
WILL REVEAL.
DID THIS CHIEF OF THE
DEPARTMENT, OF THE BROWARD
SHERIFF, ISRAEL, DID HE HAVE A
PROTOCOL THAT INSISTED TO HIS
OFFICERS, AS MOST DEPARTMENTS
HAVE SINCE COLUMBINE, 1999, A
SCHOOL ACTIVE SHOOTER IN THE
SCHOOL, YOU RUN TO ACTION, YOU
DON'T WAIT FOR THE BACK-UP, YOU
DON'T WAIT FOR SWAT TEAM, YOU
DON'T SECURE THE PERIMETER.
YOU GO IN AND TRY TO SAVE THE
CHILDREN.
IF YOU DON'T TAKE OUT THE
SHOOTER, MAYBE YOU'LL STOP THE
BLEEDING OF ONE OF THE
CRITICALLY INJURED CHILDREN
INVOLVED.
IF HE DIDN'T GIVE HIM THAT
PROTOCOL, THEN ISRAEL HAS TO GO
>> HANNITY: BERNIE KER RIG IS A
GOOD FRIEND OF MINE.
HE RAN A DIFFERENT DEPARTMENT.
ALL RIGHT.
DAN BONGENO, YOU WORKED IN THE
SECRET SERVICE.
YOU'VE BEEN IN THE NYPD.
ISN'T THIS WHAT EVERY COP TRAINS
FOR?
I'VE NEVER HEARD OF ONE, NEVER
MIND FOUR.
THEN YOU HEARD THE COMMENTS OF
ISRAEL, WHAT DO OW THINK?
>> WELL, I WAITED FOR A WHILE TO
JUMP IN ON THIS DEBATE BECAUSE
I'M PRETTY CONFIDENT FLORIDA
USES WHAT THEY CALL THE ALERT
SYSTEM FOR SCHOOL SECURITY AND
RESPONSES TO SCHOOL SHOOTING
INCIDENTS.
AND, SEAN, THAT SYSTEM, I
BELIEVE INVOLVES MULTIPLE
DEPUTIES GOING IN.
BUT HERE'S THE DISTINCTION.
I WASN'T SURE IF IT WAS THE
DEPUTY WAITING FOR SOMEONE ELSE.
BUT ONCE THE REPORTS STARTED TO
COME OUT THAT MULTIPLE DEPUTIES
RESPONDED AND STILL DIDN'T GO
IN, I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR ON
THIS, THERE IS NO RESPONSE TO
SCHOOL VIOLENCE I KNOW OF OUT
THERE THAT REQUIRES THEM NOT TO
GO IN, SET UP A PERIMETER AND
WAIT.
EVERYBODY POST COLUMBINE IS
PRETTY MUCH TAUGHT TO RESPOND
MAXIMUM TO THE PROBLEM RIGHT
AWAY.
>> HANNITY: BUT THAT DOESN'T
EXPLAIN AWAY THE 39 TIMES
THEY'RE AT THIS KID'S HOUSE OR
THE BAKER ACT IN FLORIDA THAT
WOULD ALLOW THEM TO
INSTITUTIONALIZE THIS KID.
THERE'S NEVER BEEN A CASE, SEE
SOMETHING, SAY SOMETHING.
WE HAD EVERY SINGLE SIGN,
SYMPTOM AND EVIDENCE THAT THIS
WAS THE GUY.
DOCTOR?
>> LOOK, I'VE SAID IT BEFORE AND
I'LL SAY IT AGAIN, SEAN,
POLITICAL CORRECTNESS CAN GET
PEOPLE KILLED.
IF THESE REPORTS ARE TRUE, THAT
THEY WEREN'T ALLOWED TO ENTER
THE BUILDING BECAUSE THEIR BODY
CAMERAS DIDN'T WORK, I'VE GOT A
REMINDER FOR THE SHERIFF OF
BROWARD COUNTY, FLORIDA STATUTE
ON SHIRR I HAVE'S POWERS,
SECTION 5, CHAPTER 30 SAYS THE
SHERIFF IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
NEGLIGENCE OF HIS DEPUTIES.
IT'S NOT JUST COLUMBINE.
AFTER THE PULSE NIGHTCLUB, AFTER
SAN BERNARDINO, ALL POLICE
DEPARTMENTS AROUND THE GLOBE ARE
REASSESSING THEIR PROTOCOLS.
YOU DON'T WAIT FOR THE HOSTAGE
NEGOTIATOR.
YOU DON'T SECURE THE PERIMETER.
WHEN WHETHER YOU'VE GOT A HALF
PLATED VEST IN YOUR CAR OR NOT,
WHETHER YOU'VE GOT A LONG GUN
DOESN'T MATTER.
YOU ENTER THE BUILDING TO
NEUTRALIZE THE THREAT.
THAT'S THE NEW REALITY.
IF THIS SHERIFF SAID DON'T GO IN
THERE BECAUSE WE NEED TO DO YOUR
BODY CAM SWITCHED ON, HE MUST BE
FORCED OUT OF OFFICE OR
RECALLED.
>> I BELIEVE TO USE THE
EXPRESSION NEGLIGENCE, DOCTOR,
GIVES TOO MUCH CREDIT.
>> PROBABLY.
>> THIS WASN'T NEGLIGENCE.
THIS WAS A PERSON MAKING A
CHOICE.
I HEAR GUNSHOTS GOING OFF
INSIDE, GUNSHOTS, FIRE,
GUNSHOTS, FIRE, AND YOU SIT
THERE OR YOU HIDE BEHIND A
CONCRETE BARRICADE.  THAT'S NOT
NEGLIGENCE.
THERE IS A MUCH -- I THINK THE
PRESIDENT HAD IT RIGHT.
THAT WAS A DISGUSTING RESPONSE
TO AN EMERGE ENT SITUATION.
THIS IS A NO-BRAINER.
YOU GO IN.
YOU GO TO THE ACTION.
YOU GO.
YOU DIE GOING OVER THE BERM.
TRY TO SAVE A CHILD, PUT A
TORNQUETTE ON A KID, GET THAT
ARM, DO SOMETHING, DO SOMETHING,
DO ANYTHING OTHER THAN
PROTECTING YOURSELF.
>> HANNITY: DAN BONGENO?
>> YEAH, WELL, LISTEN, SEAN,
THIS IS MORE OF A REASON TO
ALLOW TEACHERS TO ARM THEMSELVES
IF THEY'RE WILLING TO.
>> HANNITY: BUT THAT'S THE
POINT.
THEY HAD THE ARMED GUARD.
THAT WAS SCOTT PETERSON.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT
>> BUT WHAT I'M SAYING IS IF THE
TEACHER IS THERE ON THE SCENE
IMMEDIATELY, THE COP HAD TO
RESPOND FROM ACROSS THE CAMPUS.
IT WAS A LARGE CAMPUS.
THE TEACHERS ARE RIGHT THERE.
SOMETIMES WHEN YOU NEED LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN SECONDS THEY'RE
MINUTES AWAY.
UNLESS THIS GUY'S AN OLYMPIC
SPRINTER.
I'M NOT ABSOLVING HIM.
>> HE DID NOT GO IN THE
BUILDING.
HE DID NOT GO IN THE BUILDING
>> THE SHOOTER DID GO IN THE
BUILDING AND THE TEACHER WAS
ALREADY THERE.
THE SHOOTER WAS IN THE BUILDING.
>> ISRAEL DIDN'T TEACH THESE
COPS TO CLOSE ON THE ACTION, HE
SHOULD BE FIRED.
>> GERALDO, THE TEACHERS ARE
THERE ARE THERE.
>> THERE IS AN ISSUE WITH THIS
QUESTION OF ARMING TEACHERS,
ESPECIALLY IF THEY'RE VETS.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE A TIER 1
OPERATOR OR CLASSIFIED MARKSMAN.
IF THERE'S ONE PERSON IN THE
BUILDING WHO SIMPLY LAYING DOWN
FIRE IN THE DIRECTION OF THE
PERPETRATOR --
>> I THINK IT'S A TERRIBLE IDEA.
IT'S A TERRIBLE IDEA
>> IT'S MUCH, MUCH HARDER TO
KILL PEOPLE.
IN SAN BERNARDINO, ONE PERSON
HAD BEEN ARMED, IF ONE PERSON
HAD BEEN ARMED IN SAN
BERNARDINO, WE MIGHT NOT HAVE
HAD 14 PEOPLE KILLED.
>> THE WHOLE POINT, DR. GORKA,
YOU NEED GUARDS ON EVERY
FLORIDA.
YOU NEED THE PERIMETER SECURE, A
SECURITY ASSESSMENT.
IF WE DO THAT FOR EVERY SCHOOL
AND WE HAVE THE MANPOWER AND
THEY'RE ON THE FLOOR, THEY'RE IN
THE BUILDING, THAT'S WHERE THEY